réussir les Mondiaux 2023 pour préparer
les Jeux olympiques de 2024 c'est
l'objectif annoncé par les entraîneurs
de l'équipe de France de piste pour cela
ils ont dévoilé ce mardi 25 juillet la
sélection tricolore pour ce rendez-vous
ils seront 19 français à s'envoler pour
Glasgow pour ses championnats du monde
programmés du 2 au 9 août la compétition
on va voir le couteau entre les dents on
sait qu'il voyage voir l'adversité donc
je pense que néanmoins on a les moins de
bien figurer sur cette compétition parmi
les têtes d'affiches du sprint français
on retrouvera sur la piste écossaise la
ville proviennent mathildegro elle
tentera de défendre son titre en vitesse
individuelle un titre remporté lors des
Mondiaux 2022 au vélo de route nationale
de 50 ans en Yvelines moi je suis
vraiment focus sur moi je m'entraîne
enfin voilà je fais ce qu'il y a à faire
et puis et puis en tout cas voilà j'ai
pas de regret quoi qu'il arrive dans mes
préparations à chaque fois sur les
compètes je sais que je donnerai mon
maximum et que quoi qu'il arrive si il y
a le titre au bout tant mieux s'il y a
pas le titre et ben on fera un débrief
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qu'on peut modifier pour Paris
c'est ça le but quoi en endurance
l'ancien trappiste Benjamin Thomas sur
Alain des leaders de l'équipe de France
en 2022 dans les Yvelines il avait
remporté l'argent sur l'Omnium et lors
dans l'épreuve de l'Américaine il espère
faire aussi bien cette année je suis
incompétiteur donc je mentirais si je
disais que j'y vais pour pour participer
et même si c'est toujours compliqué
d'être champion du monde c'est il faut
sortir des performances incroyables pour
pour l'être des fois en banalise en
banalisent les performances oui on y va
pour on y va pour l'or et après on verra
on donne le meilleur de même lors des
derniers championnats du monde au
Vélodrome national la France avait
remporté 7 médailles dans trois en or
les Bleus s'étaient classés troisième
nation de l'épreuve